[Müzik]
Herkese selamlar sevgiler
Evet orada biraz göbeği yonttum
fotoğrafı yollarken beni daha önceden
tanıyan kaç kişi var
şimdi bugün sizle birlikte biraz daha
tam bilinmeyene gideceğiz ama böyle
sütlü tatlı bir sunum olacak merak
etmeyin çok böyle sert bir sunum
olmayacak diyelim ki yolda gidiyorsunuz
böyle bir
Alaaddin'in lambasını buldunuz
size tek bir dilek hakkı verdi ama Dilek
hakkında hile yapmak yok yani sonsuz
dilek hakkı istiyorum uyanıklığı Yok
öyle
tek bir dilek Ne istersiniz sol slayt
yine bu düşünün yani bir tane dilek
hakkım var Ve ne istemeliyim
istiyorsan sonsuz yaşa başına ne
geleceği belli değil ama sonsuz yaşa
Tamam Bunlar kanopik denilen mısır’da
kullanılan kavanozlar Çünkü niye ölümden
sonra bilmiyorlar ne var diyor ki beni
organlarımı saklayıp göm Yani ben öleyim
ama ölümden sonra yaşam olsun Çünkü o
hep çok güzel
bilmiyorsun öldükten sonra ne olacağına
bir başka hikaye
tarakato askerleri
milattan önce 200'ler Çin'in ilk
imparatoru kendisine böyle askerler
yaptırmış Muazzam diyorlar
Baksana şuna
8 bin tanesi daha çıkarılmamış her bir
biseksen boyunda
her biri biseksen
ve
Ölümden sonraki yaşamı için
basit bir numara bak
annlon nasıl yapıyor acaba
değil mi Halbuki çok basit
iki Çakmak
var bunu öğrendiğin zaman o Anna Onun
bir güzelliği kalmıyor bunu Nerede
yaşıyorsunuz
karşı tarafla buluşuyorsun randevu iyice
çözmeye başlıyorsun sırrını çözdün mü bu
oluyor işte
Anna Onun bir güzelliği var bilinmeyenin
bir güzelliği var bitiyor
İşte buradaki gibi oluyorsun ya aman be
çok salakça bir şeymiş diyorsun bu kadar
basit olmamalıydı işte ilişkilerde de
böyle bir sıkıntı var o elin arkasındaki
illüzyonu gördün mü hikaye bitiyor James
Randy hayattayken
bilinmeyenleri işte Büyücüler falcılar
illüzyonistler telekinezi hepsinin
gerçekten yapabilen birisi varsa bir
milyon dolar veriyorum dedi
hiç kimse gerçekten televizyonda
insanların önünde kameralar varken bir
mucize büyü yaratamadı falcılık
hiç kimse yapamadı hiç kimse bu bir
milyon doları alamadı ve bu sınavı
geçemedi düşün ama dünyada bir
bilinmeyen yaratmak çok kolay şu an
gördüğünüz fotoğraf 1933'te gazetede
yayınlandı locdes Gölü Canavarı
bugün İskoçya'nın Turizm geliri sırf
Lock 14 buçuk milyar dolar
14.5 milyar dolar düşün sonradan bu
gazetelere düştü gölde canavar var öyle
büyük böyle harika Gerçekten mi falan
derken iş öyle bir yere geldik ki başka
fotoğrafları falan çıktı ama fotoğrafı
ilk yapan
oğlu
üvey babası fotoğrafı çektiren kişi
1994'te ölmeden önce itiraf etti bunda
yaptık dedi
sahteydi dedi fotoğraf
8 yıl sonra BBC inananlarla birlikte
bütün Gölü 600 tekne ile aradı halen
inanıyorlar adam itiraf etti ya
kandırdık dedi halen
canavarı var diyorlar Çünkü bir
bilinmeyen her zaman güzel hep bir
mistik hep bir tatlış bu adam da itiraf
etti bu fotoğrafta sahte dedi yine düşün
Bu ikisi tarihe gelmiş en büyük kahinler
birisi Baba vanga birisi de işte
Nostradamus
nostradamus’un ve baba van’ın
hayattayken kehanetleri bu sayıda
bir tanesi İşte 6-5 bin Kehanet bir
tanesi 3000 Kehanet bu kehanetlerin
tutarlılık olanı o kadar düşük ki bak
3.000 kehanetten tutanlar yani 22 yılı
için kehanetleri bunlar
Ben de 3000 tane kehanette bulunsam
3-5'i tutar sevabına ama insanlar
inanmaya başladı
babama yanında kehanetleri 2022 yılı
için bunlardı Bunlar da zaten hepinizin
tahmin edebileceği şeyler öyle mucize
değil
ya böyle mi diyebileceğin şeyler yok ki
şimdi
Atatürk hayattayken bir sürü
saçmalığı tahmin edip ya bu ülkede
zamanında böyle işte aptallıklar
yaşanmış artık yaşanmasın diye yasalar
üretmiş Atatürk demiş ki ya işte
tarikatlar bilmem neler falcılık
büyücülük sonra da bu ceza kanuna
yerleşmiş ülkemizde büyücülük falcılık
yapmak yasak niye bilinmeyenler haber
getiriyorsun yersen hani inanana
Bu gördüğünüz şey
ne yazıyoruz yukarıya falcı Google'da
adresleriyle çıkıyorlar
Türkiye'de falcılar var Bunlar
puanlanıyor bak İstanbul'da sadece
Anadolu Avrupa Yakası Armağan çok iyi
bir falcı hayatımda gördüğüm en iyisi
falcı Kuzey muhteşem bir enerjiye sahip
insanlar falcılara puanlar veriyor
Ama tam tersi de var inanılmaz Tabii ki
ülkemizde saçmalık daniskası ötesine
gidebildiği için bak şimdi
şikayet varkom'a falcıyı şikayet ediyor
geleceği bilemedi diye
Türkiye burası ya diyor ki Bana geleceği
söyleyemedi
yani 20 lira verip
Anlatabildim mi geleceği öğrenmek
istiyor öğrenemeyince de gidip şikayet
var Ona şikayet ediyor
parayı alıp susmuş işte enerjisi
kötüymüş bilmem neymiş bu da bu da yine
Google arama sonucu büyü bozma
yazıyorsun Bak
748.000 Sonuç çıkıyor bu ülkede
unutmayın büyücülük suç
Bu arada büyü yapılabildiğine inananlar
da var da oraya geçiyorum bak büyü bozma
nasıl yapılır Zeynel bilmem ne
metafiziğin uzmanı Eski sevgiliyi geri
döndürme bak anla onun
yani ilişkide istediğin kadar Joker
hakkım var Nasıl olsa Zeynel onu getirir
sal hayvan gibi davran ama Zeynel abi
onu getirir
ve mesela Medyum perest diye birisi var
giriyorsun
[Müzik]
Çünkü Medyum pereste Bak neler var
böyle zaten önemli yani Bayburt
Aydıntepe mordor'un yanı hani
ve bunları yapabiliyor
Ak büyüler Kara büyüler
Bu ne demek ki bu ülkede buna İnananlar
var ki bu adam Aç kalmıyor ve bunun gibi
binlerce büyücü var bu ülkede bak yani
ülkenin ne durumdayız anlatabiliyor
muyum ilk gece
Dün bir tane YouTube kanalımda video
gördük
lazer tabancası su tabancası ile ateş
ediyor cin çıkarmak için
Ama buna inanıyor karşı taraf böyle
duruyor
O da cin çıkıyor diyor
çünkü
bütçe 36 milyar ama
Anla Onu olmak çok güzel bak
şimdi bu çocuğun kaldı mı Anna on bir
tarafı medyanın maymun oldu galiba
izlemeli gelecek bu çocuk
Anna onu olamıyorsun şimdi Bir insanı
tanımak için birisi size Hediye gönderdi
çiçek gönderdi Neyini merak edersiniz
bir cinsiyetine
bu yapılan bir araştırma insanlara
hediye yolluyorlar ve sorduğu sorulara
bakıyorlar cinsiyeti yani kadın mı erkek
mi aynı cinstek hediyeyi çöpe atarım iki
boyu kilosu benim gibi göbekli mi boylu
postlu mu İsim bak isim 3 sırada geliyor
kim oldu
aynı cinstek boş ver meslek Parası pulu
var mı
yaşı Bak yaş 5 sırada
bilinmeyen bir sevgili adayının Önemli
olan tarafı 5 sırada en son maddi durum
ve lokasyon şimdi nerede bütün şartlar
uygunsa gidip onu alayım
Bir insanı tanımak için
bazı sorular sormanız bazı şeyleri
bilmeniz gerekiyor ama o insanı
gerçekten tanıyabilmeniz hiç ulaşılmaz
olması muazzam bir artı getiriyor mesela
burası
hiç ulaşılmayan bir daha Çünkü bulunduğu
yerdeki yerel halk 6000 metrenin üstüne
çıkılmasına izin vermiyor Bu Rota
yasaklı hiç kimse buraya çıkamıyor O
yüzden de dünyanın al Nuh'un olarak en
özel en lüks yeri
Bu da bir yeraltı Mağarası
içine İstanbul ve Ankara birlikte
sığabiliyor dünyanın en büyük yeraltı
Mağarası
yeni keşfedildi 2000'lerde içinde daha
önce hiç görülmemiş 7 tür hayvan çıktı
maymunlar Kaplanlar her şey var ormanlar
var 200 metre yükseklikte Düşünebiliyor
musun böyle bir yer var ve Anna şu an
oraya gitmek istiyorsunuz o kadar kolay
değil ama gitmek istiyorsunuz Çünkü
bilinmeyen bilinmeyen güzeldir
ilişkilerde olduğu gibi
Bu şahıs ise Anna Onun babası
dünyanın en gizli insanlarından birisi
Çünkü çift taraflı ajanlık yapmış
Amerika'ya karşı ve böyle geziyor
Seminerler veriyor ihanetin kitabını
yazmış
ideal sevgili adayı
şimdi bilinmeyenli bir maliyeti var size
O da ne hayatta Neyi bilmiyorsun yani
senin elinde ne yok 2030 yılında Sen
nerede olacaksın 2040'ta Nerede
olacaksın işte bilinmeyen bu
2050'de Nerede olacaksın
asıl önemli olan bilinmeyen bu falcı
bunu söylüyor sana ama
işte şikayet etmen gerekiyor sonra 3
vakte Kader yersen ben de söyleyeyim
yani 3 vakte kadar içinizden bazıları
seyahate çıkacak
bu soldaki geleceğe dönüşteki aracın
eski versiyonu Bu da yeni versiyonu
Senin yeni versiyonun ne olacak
bilinmezin içerisinde çözmen gereken
mesele bu o da son slayt
ta gerçek yaşın kaç gerçekte kaçsın
tanışırsın oturaklı bir insandır
konuşmaya başladı
Hele ki sevgilisinin yanında iyice
palyaçoya dönüşür ama gerçek yaşın kaç
gerçekte kaç hissediyorsun
beyin yaşın kaç
Çünkü bir insanın hayatında çeşitli
atladığı evreler vardır
insanlar senden bir şey ister
ve onun sonucunda da bir şey kazanırsın
neden mutsuzsun bu salondaki insanların
üzgünüm ama yüzde yetmiş ikisi mutsuz
kötü taraf şu neden mutsuz olduğunu
bilmiyor
bir şeyler değişsin istiyorum
ne değişsin değişsin Bir şeyler ne
değişse şu an hayatınızda ne değişsin
istersiniz
mesela ilişki durumu değişsin isteyen
kaç kişi var
2000 kişiyiz dürüst olun kaldır
yani maddi durumu değişsin isteyen kaç
kişi var
sırf para değil mi Sırf para ya
hazır mısın
neye Hazır mısın
bilinmeyene Hazır mısın yarın sabah
uyandın
pat bir şey değişti
yani düşün ki gidelim bundan 2 bin 3000
yıl öncesinde sabah Çinli bir adamın
karısı dürtüyor kalk Bey diyor Ne diyor
ülkenin etrafında duvar öreceğiz diyor
İmparator öyle istedi
çılgınca bir şey pandemi hazır mıydın
değildin Bak şimdi maskesiz oturuyorsun
birkaç kişi hariç Hazır mısın ya bir
şeyler değişse Hazır mısın birisi kalk
gidelim dese gidebilecek misin aşkı
hazır mısın
sevilmeye hazır mısın
bazı bünyede durmuyor sevgilisi oluyor
bu
Nasıl olsa yani Yıllarca bekar bir
sevgili bulunca Nasıl olsa yenisi de
gelir diyor ve o kim seni değiştirecek o
kişi kim anla onun Kralı Kraliçesi kim
sen Nasıl birini istiyorsun
kime aşık olacaksın kimi seveceksin
kimsenin hayatını değiştirecek kimsenin
için en değerli
bir başka soru sana bir milyon dolar
versek ne Al sana bilinmeyen neyine
yarayacak senin bir milyon dolar ev
alırım onu oradan Yetmiyor yetmiyor
artık o da evde alamıyorsun o paraya
kiraya yatırırım Ee kiradan gelecek
parayla Onunla da başka ev alırım eve
üçü ile birlikte başka bir evin içine
girerim
sonra o parayı ne yapacaksın
20 milyon dolara bir yat alacak mısın
bir bilinmeyen ne zaman öleceksin
ömrün boyunca para biriktiriyorsun
biriktir biriktir biriktir Gerçi
biriktiremiyorsun da Dürüst olalım
ne zaman öleceksin Al sana bilinmeyenin
üstü
bir gün öleceksin
ve Son soru yani son bilinmeyen
sonsuzaydın son sorusu Senin hayatına
giden insanlar niye gitti niye terk
edildi Çünkü hayatındaki bilinmeyenleri
içerisinde en önemlisi bu
diğerleri para pul önemli sanıyorsunuz
ama değil hayatınızda insanlar çekip
gittiğinde Siz böyle kaldığınızda
sanıyorsunuz geri gelecekler
gelmeyecekler Çünkü sen artık sıkıcısın
sen artık bir şeysin işte burada da
dönüp ilk slayta geri geliyoruz ne
istiyorsun
ne istiyorsun
Ben 43 yaşında şunu öğrendim süren bitti
o yüzden hızlıca toplayacağım benden
sonraki insana zaman olarak saygı duymak
istiyorum
Ben 43 yaşında şunu öğrendim İlk önce
ilk istediğim şey bir laptoptu
ya siz yaşlardayken o zaman Laptop yeni
çıkmıştı laptopu Monsuno Allah'ım ne
olur laptopum olsun dedim
bir yerde satış görevlisi oldum sanayide
kapı kapı dolaştım o laptopla yanlış
istemişim yani Allah'tan bir şey
istemenin de bir yolu var hani laptopum
olsun ve bir odada oturayım istememişim
meğerse sonra Şunu öğrendim ki
para para para para para para
3 yıl boyunca hastanede süründükten
sonra öğrendim ki parayı da oraya
harcıyormuşsun
en son Şunu öğrendim ki tanınmalıyım
işte o bir parça YouTube'un Faydası oldu
ama en önemlisi seni tanıyan insanların
sana sövmemesi
Yani saygı Umarım hayatınızdan hani
benim size tek bir tavsiyem olacaksa
Tanınan biri olun ama bunun için de bir
şeyler üretin tüketerek Tanınan biri
olmayı çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]